This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. At some point in your life, you've probably encountered a problem in the built world, something that was poorly designed and the fix was obvious to you. Maybe a door that opened the wrong way, were a poorly painted marker on the road. I noticed this kind of stuff all the time, even more so now after creating this show. I'm sorry if you do, too, because you listen to this show. And mostly when we see these things, we grumble on the inside, and then do nothing. There are all sorts of reasons for our inertia.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在你生命中的某个时刻，你可能在建筑环境中遇到过问题，有些东西设计得很糟糕，而解决办法对你来说显而易见。也许是一扇开错方向的门，或者是路上画得不好的标记。我一直都能注意到这类事情，在制作了这个节目之后更是如此。如果你也因为听了这个节目而注意到这些，我很抱歉。通常当我们看到这些东西时，我们会在心里抱怨，然后什么也不做。我们产生这种惰性是有各种原因的。
We don't know how to fix it. It's not ours to fix. We could get in trouble. That's producer David Weinberg. You might notice these little design flaws for years, silently fuming, until one day. He called me instead, you know, okay, we're doing it. It was early Sunday morning, August 5th, 2001, in Los Angeles, California.
我们不知道怎么修复它。修复它不是我们的职责。我们可能会惹上麻烦。那是制作人大卫·温伯格。你可能会注意到这些小小的设计缺陷多年，默默地生气，直到有一天。他反而给我打了电话，你知道，好吧，我们要行动了。那是2001年8月5日，星期日清晨，在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶。
Richard Encrum and a group of friends were on the fourth street bridge over the 110 freeway. They were about to commit a crime. It's gonna be a high profile of dangerous situation. Not only could I get arrested, I could kill somebody, really. I was terrified of that. But let's back up. About 20 years prior, Richard Ancrum, an artist living in Orange County, was driving North on the 110 freeway. As he passed through downtown Los Angeles, he was going to merge onto another freeway, the I-5 North, but he missed the exit and got lost.
理查德·安克拉姆和一群朋友当时在110号高速公路上的第四街大桥上。他们正准备犯罪。这将是一个备受瞩目且危险的情况。我不仅可能被捕，真的，我还可能害死人。我对此感到恐惧。但让我们回顾一下。大约20年前，住在奥兰治县的艺术家理查德·安克拉姆正开车在110号高速公路上向北行驶。当他经过洛杉矶市中心时，他打算并入另一条高速公路，即5号州际公路北向，但他错过了出口，迷路了。
And for some reason, it just stuck with him. Years later, when Richard moved to downtown Los Angeles, he was driving on the same stretch of freeway where he'd gotten lost a decade before, when he looked up at the big green rectangular sign suspended above. I realize why I missed the exit is because it wasn't adequately signed. Bad way finding. The exit for the I-5 wasn't indicated on the green overhead sign. There was even a big open space where there should have been a blue and red interstate
不知为何，这件事一直萦绕在他心头。多年后，当理查德搬到洛杉矶市中心时，他正开在那段他十年前迷路的高速公路上，这时他抬头看向悬挂在上方的大型绿色长方形标志。我意识到我错过出口的原因是它没有足够的标志。寻路系统很糟糕。5号州际公路的出口没有在头顶的绿色标志上标明。甚至在应该有蓝色和红色州际公路标志的地方，还有一个很大的空白空间，
shield, and above that, it should have said north. It was clear to Richard that CalTrans, the California Department of Transportation, had made a mistake. So Richard and artist and sign painter decided to make the interstate five north shield himself and install it in the place he thought it should have been all along, high above the 110 freeway. He would call it an act of guerrilla public service. All idealist to be sort of a public servant or actually to show what you can do with artwork. You can put in plain sight and have a functioning,
而在那上方，应该写着“北”。理查德很清楚，加州交通局（CalTrans）犯了一个错误。于是，身为艺术家和标志画家的理查德决定亲自制作这个5号州际公路北向的标志，并把它安装在他认为一直都应该在的地方——110号高速公路的高处。他称之为一种“游击式公共服务”行为。所有理想主义者都想成为某种公务员，或者实际上是展示你能用艺术品做什么。你可以把它放在显眼的地方，让它成为每个人都能使用的功能性东西。
working thing for everyone to use. Richard started by studying LA freeway signs, holding up pantone swatches to perfectly match the pink color. He dangled over bridges to measure the exact dimensions of other signs. And most importantly, he downloaded the Necronomicon of California Road signage, the MUTKID. The MUTCD, the manual on uniform traffic control devices, quote, to provide for uniform standards and specifications for all official traffic control devices in California. It's not a beach read.
理查德首先研究了洛杉矶的高速公路标志，举起潘通色卡来完美匹配那种粉色。他悬挂在桥梁上测量其他标志的确切尺寸。最重要的是，他下载了加州道路标志的“死灵之书”——MUTCD。MUTCD，即《统一交通控制设施手册》，引用其目的：“为加州所有官方交通控制设施提供统一的标准和规范。”这不是一本海滩休闲读物。
I have it as more of a lazy Sunday afternoon read. All the specs are online so people can bid on projects. Richard wanted his sign to be built to the exact specifications of cow trans, which were designed to be read by motorists traveling at high speeds. The shield with a five on it is three feet, roughly high and wide. It's less than eight of an inch, barely an eighth of an inch thick aluminum. It's still pretty strong. And above that, I put the word north, and that was about 14 inches by 5 feet. And again, I used the same tight face that was there and the same signs.
我把它当作一个慵懒的周日下午读物。所有的规格都在网上，这样人们就可以竞标项目。理查德希望他的标志能按照加州交通局的确切规格建造，这些规格是为高速行驶的驾驶员设计的。带有数字“5”的盾牌大约有三英尺高和宽。它不到八分之一英寸厚，几乎只有八分之一英寸厚的铝板。它仍然相当坚固。在那上方，我放了“北”这个词，大约是14英寸乘5英尺。而且我再次使用了那里现有的相同字体和相同的标志。
I tried to match everything as close as I could, so it wouldn't be obvious. CalTrans didn't do it. Richard's brand new additions had to blend in perfectly with the existing signage, which had been collecting dirt and smog for decades. I sprayed the whole thing with a really thin glaze of grey, and knocked down the shine. After he finished it, Richard signed his name on the back of it with a black marker, like a painter signing a canvas, then came the next phase of the project, the installation, which he planned with the precision of a bank heist.
我尽量匹配所有东西，这样就不会显得很明显。加州交通局没有做这个。理查德全新的添加物必须与现有的标志完美融合，而现有的标志已经积攒了数十年的灰尘和烟雾。我给整个东西喷了一层非常薄的灰色釉料，去掉了光泽。完成后，理查德在背面用黑色记号笔签上了自己的名字，就像画家在画布上签名一样，接着是项目的下一阶段——安装，他像策划银行抢劫一样精确地计划了这次安装。
He bought a disguise, a white hard hat and an orange vest, so he'd look like a cow trans worker. Basically looked at part as best I could. And he made a decal for his pickup truck, meant to look vaguely official, that said, aesthetic deconstruction. The night before the installation Richard drove out to the site and hid some of his supplies so they'd be easy to get to the next morning. When I interviewed him he took me to the spot and showed me where he stashed his stuff.
他买了一套伪装，一顶白色安全帽和一件橙色背心，这样他看起来就像加州交通局的工人。基本上尽我所能看起来像那么回事。他还为他的皮卡车制作了一个贴纸，看起来模棱两可地像官方标志，上面写着“美学解构”。安装前一天晚上，理查德开车到现场，藏好了一些补给品，这样第二天早上就容易拿到了。当我采访他时，他带我去了那个地点，并向我展示了他藏东西的地方。
Okay we're basically here. Right now the ivy isn't that thick but it was a lot thicker and I had what basically behind that tree it stashed the ladder and the signs and stuff. After he hit his things, he climbed a tree and just sat there, going through everything in his head. I just sort of calmed myself down by being there and hanging around with it the night before. Richard was worried that he might drop the sign or one of his tools onto the road below. Drivers going 60 plus miles an hour would have no time to react if something landed on the road in front of them, or worse, onto their car. That was a scariest thing about the whole project.
好吧，我们基本上到了。现在常春藤没那么厚，但当时厚得多，我基本上在那棵树后面藏了梯子和标志之类的东西。藏好东西后，他爬上一棵树，坐在那里，在脑海中梳理了一遍所有事情。我只是通过前一天晚上在那里待着并和它待在一起，让自己平静下来。理查德担心他可能会把标志或工具掉到下面的路上。如果有什么东西掉在他们面前的路上，或者更糟的是掉在车上，时速60英里以上的司机将没有时间反应。那是整个项目中最可怕的事情。
If somebody got hurt, you know, you have to live with that. And then the project got to have to sh** can in it because it would have defeated the whole idea. But despite some reservations, Richard was pretty confident he could pull the whole thing off, and he'd gone too far to turn back. And that brings us back to the morning of August 5th, 2001. Richard did not act alone. He asked several friends to film the installation from different vantage points. Amy Inoa was one of the friends he enlisted to film. We did it at 6am or 7am on a Sunday morning. It was tense because we all thought we were
如果有人受伤，你知道，你必须带着那种愧疚生活。那么这个项目就得被废弃，因为它违背了初衷。但尽管有一些顾虑，理查德还是相当自信他能完成这一切，而且他已经走得太远，无法回头了。这把我们带回了2001年8月5日的早晨。理查德并非独自行动。他请了几位朋友从不同的角度拍摄安装过程。艾米·伊诺亚是他招募来拍摄的朋友之一。我们在周日早上6点或7点做的。当时很紧张，因为我们都以为我们要惹麻烦了。
going to get into trouble. Richard had chosen a Sunday morning to put up the sign, knowing that there would be little traffic and the morning light rising above the skyscrapers would be just right for filming. What he hadn't anticipated was that cow trans had also picked that morning to do work on the same stretch of highway. Yes, they happened to be doing some other work on the freeway just south of that sign. When they saw the cow trans workers, they thought about turning back. But I had s'mized after all this is a pretty large city that'd be more than one sying crew.
理查德选择在周日早上安装标志，因为他知道那时交通很少，而且摩天大楼上升起的晨光非常适合拍摄。他没预料到的是，加州交通局也选在那个早晨在那段高速公路上施工。是的，他们碰巧在那块标志南面的高速公路上做其他工作。当他们看到加州交通局的工人时，他们想过回头。但我推测，毕竟这是一个相当大的城市，应该不止一个施工队。
My assumption was they'd think the other guy was doing it. Richard parked his truck and when everyone was in position with their cameras, he went to work. The hardest part really was getting over the razor wire with the ladder. Once he was up on the catwalk nearly 30 feet above the highway, he started screwing in the new sine. Careful not to drop any screws on the catwalk nearly 30 feet above the highway, he started screwing in the new sign. Careful not to drop any screws on the cars below. Half way into it, we just felt like okay he's gonna get away with it. Look at that, is that amazing or what?
我的假设是他们会以为是对方在做。理查德停好卡车，当每个人都在各自的位置架好摄像机后，他就开始工作了。最困难的部分其实是带着梯子翻过铁丝网。一旦他爬上高速公路上方近30英尺高的猫道，他就开始拧上新的标志。小心不要把任何螺丝掉在下面的车上。进行到一半时，我们感觉就像，好吧，他能蒙混过关了。看那个，那太神奇了，不是吗？
Oh look, he's folding up the stuff, he's got it up. The whole thing took less than 30 minutes. As soon as it was up Richard packed up his ladder, rushed back to his truck and blended back into the city. Wow! Oh my god! Awesome! I think we all went out to breakfast together afterwards and we were super relieved and really happy. Only a small group of people knew that the Interstate 5 shield with the word North hanging above the 110 freeway was a forgery. He didn't say to us, don't tell anyone, so our friends all knew about it, and we would drive by it, and we would just all feel really happy about it.
哦看，他在收东西，他装好了。整个过程不到30分钟。标志一装好，理查德就收起梯子，冲回他的卡车，融入了城市之中。哇！天哪！太棒了！我想我们之后一起去吃了早餐，我们感到超级如释重负，真的很高兴。只有一小群人知道悬挂在110号高速公路上的带有“北”字的5号州际公路盾牌是一个伪造品。他没有对我们说“别告诉任何人”，所以我们的朋友都知道这件事，我们会开车经过它，我们都会为此感到非常高兴。
But it never sort of managed to leak out past that small group. For a while. For a while. For nine months, the secret stayed within a small community. And then Richard's friend Gary leaked the story. Oh, what the hell, Gary? Why can't you be cool? Just be cool, Gary! Richard's secret was out to CalTrans and to the press.
但它从未设法泄露给那一小群人之外。有一段时间。有一段时间。九个月来，这个秘密一直保存在一个小圈子里。然后理查德的朋友加里泄露了这个故事。哦，搞什么鬼，加里？你为什么不能酷一点？酷一点，加里！理查德的秘密被加州交通局和媒体知道了。
From the fake magnetic sign on his beat-up blue truck to a work order proclaiming rush. But he did is against the press. From the fake magnetic sign on his beat up blue truck to a work order proclaiming rush. But he did is against the law, but CalTrans says it has no plans at all to foul charges against him. After they found out what had happened, apparently they sent a corrupt, they were inspected. Richard was hoping to get his sign back
从他那辆破旧蓝色卡车上的假磁性标志，到宣称“紧急”的工作单。但他所做的是违法的，但加州交通局表示完全没有计划对他提出指控。在他们发现发生了什么事后，显然他们派了一个腐败的，他们检查了。理查德希望能拿回他的标志。
from CalTrans after they took it down. He was thinking he would hang it in an art gallery, but CalTrans didn't take the sign down. It passed the CalTrans inspection, because that's really the final test of how good the artwork is. It's stayed up for eight years, nine months and 14 days, I believe,
在加州交通局把它拆下来后。他想把它挂在艺术画廊里，但加州交通局并没有拆掉那个标志。它通过了加州交通局的检查，因为那才是艺术品质量好坏的最终考验。它挂了八年、九个月零14天，我相信，
it's not exactly accurate, but it's pretty close to that. In interviews about the incident with other news organizations, CalTrans didn't exactly condone Richard's handiwork, but they were pretty kind about it. Here's the CalTrans spokesperson at the time. He did a good job, but we don't want him to do it again. And in fact, he did such a good job
这不完全准确，但非常接近。在接受其他新闻机构关于此事的采访时，加州交通局并没有完全宽恕理查德的手艺，但他们对此相当客气。这是当时加州交通局的发言人。他做得很好，但我们不希望他再做一次。事实上，他做得太好了，
that I'd like to offer him a job application. More than eight years after Richard's sign went up, he got a call from a friend who noticed some workers taking it down. Richard contacted CalTrans to ask if he could have his sign back. By the time I tracked him down, it had already been crushed into a bale going for China. Who knows what it turned into could be a waffle iron by now. After CalTrans took down Richard's sign, they replaced it with a brand new one. But this time, they incorporated his ideas into the new design.
以至于我想给他提供一份工作申请。在理查德的标志挂上去八年多后，他接到一个朋友的电话，说看到有工人在拆除它。理查德联系了加州交通局，询问是否能拿回他的标志。等我找到他时，它已经被压成一捆运往中国了。谁知道它变成了什么，现在可能是一个华夫饼机。加州交通局拆除理查德的标志后，换上了一个全新的。但这一次，他们把他的想法融入了新设计中。
They added the five north and the shield, not only to that sign, but to additional ones up the road. A little epilogue. Richard's highway sign is a happily ever after story. The sign worked, people appreciated it, no one got hurt, thankfully. Even Count Trans was really pretty nice about the whole thing. There's another gorilla sign story out of New York City, a group that calls itself the efficient passenger project has been hanging signs in New York subway stations to tell people
他们不仅在那块标志上，还在路上的其他标志上增加了“5北”和盾牌。一个小尾声。理查德的高速公路标志是一个“从此幸福快乐”的故事。标志起作用了，人们很欣赏它，谢天谢地，没有人受伤。甚至加州交通局对整件事也相当不错。纽约市还有另一个游击标志的故事，一个自称为“高效乘客项目”的组织一直在纽约地铁站悬挂标志，告诉人们
where they can board the train to make the most efficient transfers. The project is not at all affiliated with the Metropolitan Transit Authority, but the signs look just like MTA signs, black with white helvetical lettering. They say things like, board here for best transfer to the four, five, and six trains, or board here for best transfer to F and M trains. It's the kind of knowledge that you build up over time as a regular subway rider, and this guerrilla signmaker is offering it to everyone. And though some have applauded the signs, not all New Yorkers are pleased.
在哪里可以上车以实现最高效的换乘。该项目与大都会运输署（MTA）完全没有关联，但这些标志看起来就像MTA的标志，黑色背景配白色Helvetica字体。它们写着诸如“在此上车以获得前往4、5、6号线的最佳换乘”或“在此上车以获得前往F和M线的最佳换乘”。这是你作为一名常规地铁乘客随着时间积累的知识，而这位游击标志制作者正把它提供给每个人。虽然有些人称赞这些标志，但并非所有纽约人都感到高兴。
These are secrets, some say, that people should have to earn. They will unbalance the cars, they say, leave signage to the experts. The MTA, for their part, is taking down the signs as fast as they go up. MTA spokesman Kevin Ortiz told us in an email that, quote, posting of the signs is considered an act of vandalism. Point being, if you decide to undertake an act of guerrilla public service, just know it may not be received as such.
有些人说，这些是秘密，人们应该自己去发现。他们说，这会破坏平衡，把标志留给专家吧。MTA方面则在标志出现后尽快将其拆除。MTA发言人凯文·奥尔蒂斯在电子邮件中告诉我们，引用：“张贴这些标志被视为一种破坏行为。”重点是，如果你决定进行某种游击式公共服务，要知道它可能不会被那样接受。
There have been a bunch of fascinating extra legal public service interventions since we aired this story a few years ago. A round up of those after this. The efficient passenger project isn't the only group that's gotten ambitious with modifying New York City subway signage. 99 PIs co-listed is here to talk about a similar intervention and some other creative works of guerrilla urbanism. That group actually led me to the story of a Rhode Island school of design student named Orion Murphy who also took up the challenge of Subway signage. And his project was pretty simple but also pretty clear. He installed a bunch of signs about exits at I level about five feet up on stair risers. The idea was that train passengers looking at the staircase from below could then figure out if those steps would take them where they wanted to go.
自从我们几年前播出这个故事以来，出现了一系列引人入胜的法外公共服务干预措施。在此之后会有一个总结。高效乘客项目并不是唯一一个在修改纽约地铁标志方面有野心的组织。99PI的联合制作人在这里谈论类似的干预措施和其他一些游击城市主义的创意作品。那个组织实际上引导我找到了罗德岛设计学院一名叫奥里昂·墨菲的学生的故事，他也接受了地铁标志的挑战。他的项目非常简单，但也非常清晰。他在楼梯立管上安装了一堆大约五英尺高、视线水平的出口标志。这个想法是，从下方看向楼梯的乘客可以判断这些台阶是否会带他们去想去的地方。
Sterisers are basically the flat front of a stair that you see from the front. Yeah, so if you're walking up the staircase, it would be right in front of you and you just sort of look at it and be like, oh, yeah, that's the exit I want. And you'd be able to, you know, more easily find your way through the system.
楼梯立管基本上就是你从正面看到的台阶的平坦部分。是的，所以如果你走上楼梯，它就会在你面前，你只需看一眼就会觉得，哦，是的，那是我想要的出口。你就能更轻松地在系统中找到路。
And there's a lot of real estate that signs haven't occupied all that much, actually. Yeah, that's interesting. And of course, like the other sign project though, these got taken back down and clearly the empty is not particularly open to gorilla innovations. No, they're not. And you've covered a bunch of these on the website over the years. Oh yeah, I'm super intrigued by these kinds of gorilla public service projects and those unpaid activists who do them. I mean, there's creative people who see everyday problems as civic design opportunities.
而且有很多标志还没有占据太多的空间，实际上。是的，这很有趣。当然，像其他标志项目一样，这些也被拆除了，显然MTA对游击创新并不是特别开放。不，他们不是。而且多年来你在网站上报道过很多这样的案例。哦，是的，我对这类游击式公共服务项目以及那些做这些事的无薪活动家非常感兴趣。我的意思是，有创造力的人把日常问题视为公民设计的机会。
And mostly, of course, their work gets removed, but in some cases, these projects actually lead to something more permanent. Kind of like the highway sign that David talked about in our piece. Exactly. And up here in Northern California, there's another group called the San Francisco
当然，大多数情况下，他们的工作会被移除，但在某些情况下，这些项目实际上导致了一些更持久的东西。有点像大卫在我们节目中谈到的那个高速公路标志。没错。在北加州，还有另一个组织叫旧金山交通局，当然，这是对该市交通局的恶搞。他们的团队已经在城市周围合法地建造了一些游击自行车道。通常他们只是用普通的橙色交通锥标出这些车道，城市可以随时捡走。由于它们会被拿走，他们主要做的是突出当前道路的设计问题。
Transformation Agency, which is, of course, a spoof on the city's transportation agency. And their crew has legally built a number of gorilla bike lanes around the city. And often they just kind of mark these out with ordinary orange traffic cones, which the city could just pick up and haul off. Since they get taken away, what they mainly do is highlight design problems with the current roads. Right. Yeah, in a lot of cases, yes. But in late 2016, they decided to create a protected bike lane on a stretch of road along
对。是的，在很多情况下，是的。但在2016年底，他们决定在沿着金门公园的一段道路上创建一条受保护的自行车道。他们使用了所谓的“软撞击”或“安全撞击”柱，它们有几英尺高，上面有这些小反光条。你在路边见过它们。这些提供了可见和物理的存在，但它们也很容易被撞倒，所以它们不会真的对汽车造成伤害。但城市并没有只是拆掉这些柱子，而是做了一件非常了不起的事情。他们同意采纳这个想法，并在同一地点安装受保护的车道。出于法律原因，他们不能直接留下最初安装的柱子，但想法是一样的。
Golden Gate Park. And they used what are called soft hit or a safe hit post, which are a few feet high, and they have these little reflective stripes. You've seen them before on the side of a road. And these provide a visible and physical presence, but they're also easy to knock over, so they don't really pose at the injured a car. But instead of just taking the post down, the city did something pretty remarkable. They agreed to run with the idea and install protected land on that same spot. For legal reasons, they couldn't just leave up the post that had been put there first place, but same idea.
我的意思是，对于一小群自行车安全活动家来说，这似乎是一个相当大的胜利。是的，这对旧金山交通局的这些人来说绝对是一个三分球。它实现了他们的三个目标：第一，引起对不安全状况的关注；第二，提高骑行者和行人的安全；第三，让城市参与到更快速、更有效的安全改进中来。所以，我的意思是，我们谈论了发生在加州的案例。你知道，我们是一群特别吵闹的左派之类的人。我的意思是，这在其他地方也会发生吗？
I mean, that seems like a pretty big win for like a really small group of people that are activists for bike safety. Yeah, it was totally a three point shot for these guys at the transformation agency. It met their three goals of one drawing attention to unsafe conditions, two increasing safety for cyclists and pedestrians, and three getting the city on board
是的，确实会。这并不完全是加州独有的。纽约的团队也以安装游击自行车道而闻名。在西雅图，有一个叫“相当礼貌的西雅图人”的组织，实际上做了一条最初被拆除的车道。交通部门对此非常友好。他们礼貌地提出将柱子归还给安装者。最后，他们实际上同意把那条游击车道装回去。所以洛杉矶有活动，旧金山有活动，西雅图有活动。这是西海岸的自由派行为吗？是的，看起来确实是。而且在我们自己的后院也有很多。
with more rapid and effective safety improvements. And so this is, I mean, we've talked about ones that happened in California. You know, we're particularly rowdy bunch of leftists and such. I mean, does it happen in other places? Yeah, it does. It's not totally unique to California. And Cruz in New York have been known to install guerrilla bike lanes. And in Seattle, there's this group called the reasonably polite Seattleites that actually
我今年早些时候谈到的一个特别的组织，叫旧金山公共长椅项目。他们的重点与其说是道路安全，不如说是通过安装免费长椅让城市变得更宜居。所以我联系了他们的创始人进行了一次99PI专题报道，他说，基本上，他曾在董事会和委员会工作过，他致力于推广公共空间，但他发现建造长椅更有成就感。在过去的40年里，他实际上在城市周围安装了70多张长椅，并且随着他的捐赠，他不断改进设计。
made a lane that got taken down initially. And the DOT was like really nice about it. They politely offered to return the posts to the installers. And then finally, they actually agreed to just put that girl a lane back up. So there's activity in LA, there's activity in San Francisco, activity in Seattle. Is this a West Coast liberal thing? Yeah, it kind of seems like it. And there's a lot of them in our own backyard.
那么这是怎么运作的呢？他从来没有得到许可，还是不管怎样都我行我素？嗯，有时他会获得许可证，或者他会获得某种批量许可证，这使它们更便宜。但其他时候，他只是利用城市法规中的漏洞，如果你符合正确的标准并且不阻碍人行道，这些漏洞允许放置人行道家具。所以他找到了放置它们的空隙。在大多数情况下，你知道，有人要求在特定地点放置长椅，然后他们同意留意它。
There's one in particular, too, that I talked to earlier this year, called the San Francisco Public Bench Project. And their thing isn't so much about road safety, is it is about just making the city a nicer place to live by installing free benches. So I contacted their founder for a 9-EYMPI feature, and he said, basically, like he's been on boards and committees
如果社区反馈是积极的，长椅就会成为社区永久的景观。没错。他还为任何想DIY并接过这一重任的人提供模板和说明。所以“请求原谅比请求许可更容易”。
He's worked on promoting public space, but he really finds just building benches to be more rewarding And over the past 40 years, he's actually installed over 70 benches around the city and he keeps improving his design as he gives to And so how does that work? Does he just never gets permission to do him or just doesn't rogue no matter what? Well, sometimes he gets permits or he gets sort of bulk permits which make them cheaper And so how does that work? Does he just never gets permission to do them or just doesn't rogue no matter what? Well, sometimes he gets permits or he gets sort of bulk permits which make them cheaper. But other times he just works with these loopholes in the city codes which allow for sidewalk furniture if you kind of meet the right criteria and you don't obstruct sidewalks. So he sort of found the gaps to put them in. And in most cases, you know, somebody requests a bench for a specific spot and then they agree to keep an eye on it.
我想这就是基本想法。是的。所以我们在道路和人行道等建筑空间中有干预措施，但还有一类与绿色空间相关的游击活动。确实有。游击园艺这个词涵盖了很多领域，但本质上它指的是任何在人们不应该种植的地方进行的种植活动。所以没有许可证的社区花园就是一个简单的例子。这些可以是关于美化、激进主义、食品生产或目标的组合。所以这实际上是自下而上的城市规划的草根反应。
And then if the community feedback is positive, the bench becomes this permanent picture of the neighborhood. Right. And he also offers templates and instructions to anybody who wants to kind of DIY this and kind of take up the mantle too. So it's easier to beg for forgiveness and to ask for permission.
是的，在很多情况下，它可以是小规模和渐进的，比如用更好的绿化填补空地。你实际上可以在网上找到描述如何建造所谓的“种子地”之类的食谱和设计说明。这不仅仅是关于美，真的。他们试图在环境中创造一些功能性的东西。是的，我的意思是，旧金山有一个游击嫁接组织。他们的想法是，我的意思是，旧金山是一个相当绿色的城市。
I think that's the basic idea. Yeah. So we got interventions in built spaces, like roads and sidewalks, but there's also a class of grill activity related to green spaces, too. Indeed, there is. The phrase grilligardoning covers a lot of ground, but essentially it refers to any active
没错。我们有很多绿化，但设计上大多是无菌的，因为他们不想要水果，造成混乱并吸引动物。而这些人正在城市里的树木上嫁接结果实的树枝，试图提供像当地食物来源这样的东西，这非常棒。哇。他们不在乎食物造成的混乱之类的吗？嗯，我想他们的想法是，你知道，利大于弊。
planting where people aren't supposed to plant. So a community garden without a permanent would be a sort of simple example. And these can be about beautification, activism, food production, or a combination of goals. So it's literally grassroots reaction to top down urban plant. Yeah, in a lot of cases, it can be pretty small scale and incremental, like filling in vacant lots with nicer greenery. You can find actually recipes and design instructions online describing how to build what are called seed lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things.
没错。到目前为止，这些干预措施都是关于为公共利益创造更好的城市环境，但并非每一个改变标志的人都是纯粹为了他人的利益。哦，是的，不，不。在这个光谱的另一端绝对有例子。有一个人特别刚从中国的新闻中出现，他因为在街道中间画箭头而被抓。而且，你知道，是在光天化日之下，我的意思是，周围有车，他被视频拍到了。而且，你知道，那里已经有一个转弯箭头了，
And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to be able to do a whole lot of things. And then we're going to just about beauty, really. They're trying to create something functional in the environment. Yeah, I mean, there's this group in San Francisco of gorilla grafters. And their idea is, I mean, San Francisco's a pretty green city.
但他画了这个向前箭头，因为他基本上想让他的通勤更快。他有一些论点说，哦，我们可以在这个路口多用一些向前箭头，但这显然是一个自私的行为。所以他把一条转弯车道变成了一条可选的直行和转弯车道。
Right. We have a lot of greenery, but it's mostly sterile by design because they don't want fruit, creating messes and attracting animals. And these guys are grafting fruit-bearing branches on the trees in the city to try to provide like local food sources, which is pretty neat. Wow. And they don't care about the food messes and stuff. Well, I think their idea is that, you know, the good outweighs the bad.
没错。然后他因此被罚款了。《99%隐形》本周由大卫·温伯格制作。他的节目《十号公路之下》是KCRW的一个持续系列，讲述了生活在洛杉矶十号高速公路以南社区的人们的亲密故事。去看看吧。《99%隐形》团队包括艾弗里·特罗尔福德、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、谢里夫·尤瑟夫、德莱尼·霍尔、塔伦·马扎，作曲家肖恩·里亚尔，高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔，数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德，以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作。
Right. So far, these interventions have been about creating a better urban environment for the public good, but not every single one of these sign changers are doing it solely for other people's benefit. Oh yeah, no, no. There's definitely examples on the other into this spectrum. And there's a guy in particular who just hit the news from China who got caught painting an arrow in the middle of the street. And it was, you know, in broad daylight, I mean, there's cars around, he's captioning on video. And, you know, there's a turn arrow there already,
我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样热爱贴纸的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论，你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但真正的99PI总部在99pi.org。RadioTopia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
but he pointed this forward arrow because he wanted to make his commute faster, basically. And he had some argument that, oh, we could use more forward arrows at this intersection, but it was a pretty clearly self-ish act. So he took a turning lane and turned it into a optional go-forward and turning lane.
但他画了这个向前箭头，基本上是因为他想让自己的通勤更快。他提出了一些论点，说哦，我们可以在这个路口多用一些向前箭头，但这显然是一种自私的行为。所以他把一条转弯车道变成了一条可选的直行和转弯车道。
Exactly. And then he got fine for it. 99% of visible was produced this week by David Weinberg. His show Below the Ten is an ongoing series from KCREW that tells intimate stories about the people who live in neighborhood south of the Ten Freeway in Los Angeles. Check it out. 99% of visible is Avery Trollford, Emmett Fitzgerald, Shreveusef, Delaney Hall, Taren Mazza, composer Sean Rial, senior producer Katie Mingle, digital director Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K OW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Robbe in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
没错。然后他因此被罚款了。本周的《99%无形》由大卫·温伯格制作。他的节目《十号公路之下》是KCRW的一个系列节目，讲述了居住在洛杉矶十号高速公路以南社区的人们的亲密故事。去看看吧。《99%无形》的制作团队包括艾弗里·特罗尔福德、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、谢里夫·尤瑟夫、德莱尼·霍尔、塔伦·马扎、作曲家肖恩·里尔、高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心制作，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心制作。
We are part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation, and sticker loving listeners, just like you. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or we're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI dot org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样热爱贴纸的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论，你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但真正的99PI总部在99PI.org。RadioTopia。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。